il y a trois ans quand noël gaultier a
dit à sa nièce julie qu'il voulais
raccrocher ses filets la jeune femme n'a
pas hésité une seconde
elle a repris le permis de pêche à la
fascine de son oncle c'est quelque chose
qu'ils ont toujours fait ici moi j'ai
grandi là dedans c'était normal
pratiquement d'avoir montage donc est
important que cas continue simon en
quarts étaient y en avait pu pillon
j'avais l'impression que ça se pouvait
poker n'est pus l'horticultrice de
métier s'est donc sorti les mains de la
terre pour les mettre dans le fleuve
saint laurent
tous les jours entre avril et novembre
julie va relever ses filets alors à
marée basse c'est on vient voir si on a
des poissons à l'intérieur de la cage
mais se met un vent te de juillet un
pote poisson c'est la surprise du jour
ce qui est plutôt exceptionnelle car en
moyenne julie pêche quelques 25 tonnes
de poisson par an
kaplan éperlans art en anguille grand
corégone époux le mans julie détient
l'un des cinq derniers permis de pêche à
la fascine au canada la fascine
seul le nom des branchages avec lesquels
étaient pressés des filets à l'origine
carla marie redescend ils sont dirigés
vers leurs vers le large puis le large
mais il est barré par la grande elle qui
va diriger tout simplement aux
descendants tranquillement le poisson
vers la petite porte à l'intérieur de la
cage le principe est simple deux grands
filets agissent comme entonnoir pour
capturer des poissons à marée haute dans
une grande cage et les récupérer à marée
basse c'est un amalgame de plusieurs
connaissances qui sait faire des
européens à issy les premiers relations
normales gamme de pleine connaissance
selon la géographie selon le lieu selon
les types de poissons et tout en 1871 il
y avait près de 1400 permis de pêche à
la fascine au québec au fil des
décennies le nombre de pêcheurs a
diminué et dans les années 2000 le
gouvernement québécois a racheté des
permis de ce qui était encore en
activité
noël gaultier a refusé l'offre et il est
ravi que sa nièce reprennent le flambeau
transmis de génération en génération
dans la famille
mais l'attraction quand tu continues à
du coeur pour ça ils continuent à
l'aider la conseiller et ne doute pas un
instant de son succès tout le monde veut
nous produit les restaurateurs viennent
nous voir nous demande nous demandent
nos demandes mais le présentement
on est confiné à notre boutique pour
vendre au détail c'est julie qui
transforme ses poissons pour les vendre
soit frais soit congelés aux
particuliers dans sa petite boutique de
lens au sac
les restaurateurs de la région réclament
eux aussi les poissons de julie mais ils
devront attendre les normes sanitaires
imposées par le gouvernement exige des
investissements que julie ne peut pas
encore se permettre d'ici là le bouche à
oreille fonctionne à merveille
notamment parce que les pêcheries
charlevoix sont sur le circuit
agrotouristique de charlevoix une région
qui encourage depuis plusieurs années le
développement et la consommation des
produits locaux
julie est pour l'instant la seule qui
vend des produits du fleuve dans ce
circuit ça apporte à l'économie dans la
région qui est qui qui qui n'était faire
le projet se répondent du tourisme mais
aussi au niveau l'agroalimentaire d'être
vraiment présent pour répondre à toute
la chaîne de tout ce qu'on a envie de
manger maintenant notre poisson qui qui
peut être récolté gabriel cadiot gagnon
a elle aussi repris la ferme de ses
parents elle partage les mêmes valeurs
que judy je pense qu'il ya de la place
pour ce type de commerce la piste est de
retour à la terre à nos enfants est de
valoriser et de re re de se réapproprier
les techniques que nos enfants at on mis
en place il ya pas beaucoup de gens qui
ont vu ça dans leur vie comme ça c'est
magique d'assister à ça c'est unique je
me suis rendu compte que c'était pas
juste la page des gauthier qu'il fallait
maintenir en vie c'est un type de page
le mont but moi je travaillais ce qu'il
soit bien ancrée et quelles que puissent
pas être complètement arrêtés ou
disparaître
donc il faut tout sortir julie est en
train de faire les démarches pour que la
pêche à la fascine soit inscrite au
patrimoine mondial immatériel de
l'unesco
ce qui serait un autre moyen de la
préserver